this podcast and every other podcast I
make is supported by patreon they got
this episode a little bit early plus an
Extended Cut there's like an extra two
minutes of us just babbling at the start
that they got access to so if you want
to support the show and help us make
more cool stuff including more animated
episodes which is mostly the goal please
consider helping out at patreon.com
uh The Last of Us TV show reviews went
up this morning they're good right they
did at midnight very good people
excellent it had a hundred percent for a
very long time
um who gave it something less than 10
let's let's focus the podcast on them
for an hour oh one of the criticisms was
one that's like almost unfair which was
well I think I still think the game's
better how quick is that
oh
I'm gonna Flex super hard
um so I was with Neil last night at
1201. we were sitting on this
um
couch kind of in back in the back area
that's the flex you have a couch well
Doug that's amazing that's the level of
success that the audience can dream of
like you've become a big act to like
Troy yeah you too can have a canopy
um
yeah it was the it was The Last of Us
Premiere yeah uh last night and so we
were we had a wonderful night and we got
to watch it not only with all of the a
majority of the the crew uh most of the
cast
um and a lot of of course the the uh
Mucky mucks and our betters at HBO but
also they had like 130 of fans that uh
they opened the doors to and and we're
like we were here because of you we want
to celebrate this with you it doesn't
feel right to do without you so there's
a huge contingent of people that were
just there as fans uh watching and to
hear them react to everything to hear
because I've only been watching it so
far on like my iPad and like not even
final VFX
um a lot of it hasn't been mix there's
ADR that's missing it's it's like maybe
60 to 70 percent complete but all of the
the materials there uh but just not
finalized or polished and I've already
always already I've every episode okay
God I've been blown away
um but to see it on that huge of a
screen with an audience and hear the
gasps hear the crying
um hear the laughs it was it was just it
was infectious
um you only watched the first thank you
thank you the first episode is a really
long episode I think it's like 72
minutes I'm gonna be a little bit long
um it was actually originally two
episodes and they ended up cutting it
into one uh one big episode uh there's a
lot of onboarding that that happens
um uh with the first episode and and
then we're into the world we're into the
characters we're into the story and
that's where it just starts to go I mean
just it takes off episode three I keep
telling people you get to episode three
you're just you're done like we own you
um it is
one of the most original
um
compelling beautiful tragic
heartbreaking
episodes so far of the entire series but
we're sitting there at 1201 and Neil
looks at me we're kind of like the
parties started to wind down we've had
this incredible night
and
um just looking at each other going I
can't believe we're here and
um all the people that were there and
and how much they've enjoyed
um watching it and being a part of this
and this new influx of people and now
this 10-year tenure of uh other people
who have been with us for so long
and he just goes review scores are up
you want to look at it it's like let's
do it and it was just
seeing them roll in in real time and I
was like holy [ __ ] man you gotta hit and
that never happens for video game
adaptations
sort of but that's more of a ttrpg which
uh but is that more the book than the
game yeah but it's a little muddy like I
think I think Witcher did a fantastic
job of adapting something that was
primarily known for being in that video
game Space yeah um but they also really
there's there's a quite a bit of
Divergence with with both of those
things too Arcane really can't say that
it's a true adaptation this is like a
very direct down the line yeah that's
fair Arcane is not really an adaptation
no it's just an election
yeah League adjacent yeah yeah that's
I'm I'm really excited about it like I
keep
having this thing where you know so many
video game adaptations are not great and
I've been let down so many times but the
trailers look so good in a way that I I
don't feel like I'm being pandaed to as
a fan I feel like I'm being reassured
and I think that's a really specific
marketing approach of hey we're telling
you that we're not going to screw this
up not did you like that reference like
they're very very different they're even
going further right they're showing
rather than telling with that they're
kind of putting it all out there and
kind of yeah I like them in the same way
that I think and or there are a lot of
calls that happened across Disney also
really enjoyed andal but I think what
that did was it besides just being a
great show
it should we legally do this without
Austin here
bye now
I need to start a bit early today I
actually think it's right that we
disrespect him by talking about handle
yeah that's what he gets
Jesus but what Andor did was it said hey
if you make a show like this
people will respond to it and I heard
someone say this last night it's not fan
service it's story service and if you
service the story as opposed to and
focus on that as opposed to trying to
service your fans then I think you end
up making a better product and that's
what they did there's such a passionate
love
with Craig there is incredible
connection uh and oversight with Neil
and then both of them are two of the
greatest writers in Hollywood right now
I mean they're they're insane so if you
put that together and then you continue
to build upon that with an incredible
cast the the cinematography is
incredible one of the best production
designers I've ever seen it's it's
stupid so like Craig Mason puts it best
he goes I cheated I started with the
best story there's a lot of people that
start with are really not not that great
of a story good premise but not
necessarily like ah yeah like I mean
Assassin's Creed amazing premise but
starts to get very muddy very quickly
yeah because they've had to just
I actually somewhat don't have friends
to work in um film and TV come to me and
I'm like hey this video game license do
you think that we can do it uh oh like
what do you think of the story in this
game someone has approached me for this
whatever that happens to me pretty often
and I even have certain people who work
in development in TV who I will play
games for because they aren't Gamers so
I'm like sure come over I'll play
through this for you so you understand
it I would say 90 of the time they end
up going we can't do this it's not going
to work I can't do it like here's a
question I had last night inside could
you see I'm thinking about like truly
successful
um influential
it would ruin it right it would like
somehow retroactively ruin the game no
it wouldn't make any sense yeah I do
think that that's definitely one that
experienced the story by participating
in it whereas I feel like the last of us
obviously that happens too but even that
opening like you show somebody the
opening of The Lost of us and they're
gonna be like oh yeah yeah we could do
this oh I'm crying it's very it's very
like cinematicy yeah like it like Last
of Us plays like a HBO show to start off
with right like to a degree there's a
lot of and I mean that as a compliment
like it plays as Peak TV yeah yeah so so
it makes it makes perfect sense
I think a lot of Sony honestly a lot of
Sony first party stuff
um absolutely like makes sense for that
so I can see here's where most people
mess up they try to make video games
into movies and movies into video games
and that's all trying to make movies
into video games
it don't do it please it doesn't it's
very very lazy
it's remember this is it what is a what
is a a video game look like when you can
you still make it compelling if you
remove the video game element
and that to me is is the real trick is
is most people try to again like you
said a lot of Pander to the audience
it's like don't just tell a good story
and if it's a good enough story it'll
hold up in any medium but I'm very
curious like people were talking about
now there's the buzz about the Bioshock
movie
which I guess
I I guess I could see that if they go
rapture
I could see that being done in two hours
but then what like so the thing about
Bioshock is it's Rapture it's Ein Rand
it's a very like specific political
landscape that sure inhabit through a
story that is told specifically through
gameplay like the the the twist
of Bioshock is you were doing this
because you were told to the whole time
well my my big thing is who do you cast
as Andrew Ryan but what does Andrew Ryan
even do in a movie version of that game
like what is it would be retroactively
adding stuff to it
oh not bad but that said Mike I think
you could say knives out anything and
I'd be like you know what yeah yeah
you can put together a script we'd be
interested in hearing from The Hitman
guy like you're like yeah yeah we could
make that into anything I don't know
when a Bioshock movie looks like because
I think that Bioshock at its core is
so rich because it's a video game I
haven't I don't doubt someone could do
it but I don't know what it looks like I
think kindlebeat does a great job of
building out worlds and also and also
introducing us to characters so there's
my thing is do I want to spend more time
in there as somebody else because I've
already done it as me and that that to
me is what I think there is
this guy sounds familiar
yeah you shall have but I I know what
you mean though it's like if I've
already it's there's um oh God I forget
who I'm quoting but it's the old the old
adage of the probably you the old adage
of like if this isn't the most
interesting moment in this purse
character's life and this isn't the most
interesting character then don't tell a
story and I think that if games have or
if the game the game of Bioshock has
told you the most interesting events
about your shock through the most
interesting eyes to see those events
through then there is a compelling thing
like where would you find the next thing
and and that doesn't mean that's not
necessarily a barrier you can find a
better story but like that's why Last of
Us make sense or The Witcher makes sense
is is they've found they they stuck with
the same protagonist and they've told a
similar or a Jason story or you know I
don't know how close it is with last of
us but like I from the trailer it looks
like it's following a lot of the same
beats and structure right so so that
makes that makes sense but also the
World building is an angle in and that's
you know as you say like a well-built
world
can be the chessboard that you can put a
Knives Out in when people when when you
say like I'll put Knives Out in and that
kind of works anything
Knives Out is is a structure a story a
story framework you can place into a
pre-existing world so it works in the
context if you take any you could take
Knives Out in Star Wars that sounds cool
um game storytelling I I think it was
was it some was it something that came
up when I was talking with I think it's
a was it a Nintendo I think it was a
Nintendo a conversation with some
Nintendo designers years ago where they
basically were talking about the idea of
scenario and why that exists in kind of
uh Japanese game development and this
idea of explain sorry well the idea of
story story being something a story and
theming and how those things are
separated essentially and it's it's not
an original thing it's it's been thought
about many times but like theming would
be Star Wars universe that's a cool
place to be it's a place you want to
visit it's a it's a place rich with
potential for stories but the story
would be and there's this kid who's
always dreamed of being a fighter pilot
right and those two things you can take
one and put it into the other and with
games
often the kind of the the story The the
thing you're going to end up the the
protagonist's arc you're going to be
telling is very straightforward it's you
know uh Kratos needs to go and punch a
lot of things right that's your those
that's a framework that you're working
within and and games excel at World
building around that and going well we
can wrap it in all of these things and I
would say Kratos is an example of like
where it's been around long enough that
actually the protagonist story is also
becoming rich and good and cool it's a
bad example of the book I guess Doom
would be a better example of like the
protagonist is doing their thing but the
framework around them is what is
compelling I guess my point is with
Bioshock you've got that world you tell
a million stories in that world you
could it would be interesting to see
Rapture at its height right it would be
interesting to see the fall of rapture
it would be interesting to see a movie
that kind of went to a completely
different moment in that time or follows
a young Andy Ryan who's building it you
guys are on now
he's Young
I guess
frankly I don't remember the name of the
protagonist the fire shook one
I would struggle to Jack Jack you're
right
Jack
um that's it though I don't really
remember that much about him uh outside
of that I I mean you could make a very
interesting case for the fall of rapture
being a sort of
apocalyptic
um I just again my thing with Bioshock
is I I always like that world is very
cool I don't doubt somebody can do it
why though and I guess that's the thing
right I thought the same way about the
loss of us though as well that I was
like I think this is one of the best
stories
in video games ever I think it's
brilliant and it's perfect and why but
now I'm like you know what maybe I will
take a little bit more of that because
it looks so good so I guess the part of
the marketing has to be proving in the
why
because it doesn't it doesn't seem like
it's dramatically different but that's
that's the truth of pitching anything
especially why why is the pitch yeah
like and I I think that if part of the
pitch is because this one was successful
it's a failed pitch I think it's going
to be a very popular one
um I think there's a lot for people to
go well this is what they did like I
remember there's a game we were working
on when Uncharted was just hitting all
the marks it was getting all the awards
and there was the the directors are
going to say we want to do it the
Naughty Dog way I was like no you don't
want to do the Naughty Dog way because
you're not doing it the Naughty Dog way
you're trying to get the Nutty dog
Awards and there's a difference the
reason why you get those accolades the
reason why you get those review scores
the reason why you get those sales and
more than anything the impact people
going [ __ ] this is a great game is
because of all the process you can't
short shortcut your way to that and say
that well we want to get we're doing it
cinematically uh I think that even games
fail to do the things that the movies
adaptation or the TV adaptations they're
trying to do as well where they are
trying to adapt another story into
theirs and make the same mistakes that
TV shows do the best the best pitches
are something which is just complete
swing away and something original
originality Still Remains like the most
successful way of pitching or like in
the case of like Tron yes this is a
franchise but I went to Disney with like
a two sentence here's my angle on Tron
and I don't think anyone's done this
before I think it's interesting and
that's the that's ultimately like the
fact that I had evidence I could do it
the fact that I had a team the fact that
I had other games and successes or
whatever was great but I sold them with
like an emotional kind of here's a story
you've not heard before but if it's
aliens what if it's aliens I watched
sicario for the first time the other
night what'd you think brilliant loved
it adored it even
um and
it's that that one like I was frustrated
by because everything I've ever heard
about it was how good the directing is
which it is but also that screenplay was
so clearly very good that when you're
watching it I was like damn I want to
read this screenplay it's written by
Taylor Sheridan who was also the show
runner I believe is the correct title at
least creator of uh Yellowstone
oh wait
is that right
yeah
everyone's telling me to watch
Yellowstone valleystone's this weird
thing in America where it's like isn't
it like very massively successful but
like outside of major cities like a very
uh
all of Australia is watching it I I
don't know anyone in the years
it's just starting to come in in the UK
because it's like a western right it's
like uh
yeah I thought it was super Fringe was
like oh Kevin Costner what are you doing
uh like putting about pasture but then
apparently yeah not only not only that
but it's good apparently like there are
three seasons of it as well um
and then two spin-ups so it's definitely
successful we're all just out of the
loop but um when I was reading up on
Taylor Sheridan after that who someone I
previously didn't know anything about I
just looked him up because I was like
this is so clearly a very good
screenplay
um it turns out his approach to
everything that he's written which I
imagine the pitch of Yellowstone comes
into that was to you know write whatever
he wanted is the first pass and then go
through it and say what are the pieces
of this where I'm not doing anything
differently to things I've done before
he was like I didn't try to compare
myself to what other people have done
before I try to compare it to what I
have done before yeah where do I make it
very different
um to everything I've ever done and I
was like that's a really good standard
to hold yourself to because it can be
easy to fall into Comforts when creating
really anything or pitching anything
he's like make my own [ __ ] different not
only that but how how Fearless One would
have to be who it is
it's Austin can you be here for 8 30
please wow you know what Austin's doing
differently showing up last
night
this is a big trick
devil is in the details I do want to
point out we are looking at a
disconnected Mac Tower in the back
that's not a good sign yeah that's
actually been disconnected for years but
just been in my desk here and I was like
why is this getting using space it
hasn't been fun it should go behind me
yeah
months
yep yep uh what are we talking about
what are you talking about well what I
was going to say was uh we were talking
about uh Taylor Swift and we're talking
about Taylor Sheridan and
um the Taylor Sheridan verse yeah
uh
the the fact that
the temptation to rest on one's Laurels
and also to not
you are doing something different right
uh to to say hey I want to have a um
a western that is headed by Kevin
Costner maybe that was the pitch who
knows
um internally but to go I'm gonna try to
do something I haven't done already when
someone goes well we just want to make
sure that it's got that taylor-shared
and Flair make sure it has that
signature thing that we love so much
like I would imagine Craig Mason is
being told that too or anybody uh Mike
White or anybody who's had something
truly successful if they can adopt that
same philosophy of going I'm not going
to do what I did before that's
terrifying I mean he was an actor to
start with and uh I think is a very good
example so is Mike White
is he
Mike White has been in stuff I remember
he was in that movie the good girl with
Jennifer Aniston hmm
um well I know that part of what he said
about writing sicario was that uh years
of acting made him allergic to
Exposition and it is definitely uh a
screenplay that is written largely
without Exposition sort of with the
exception of
um a character who in the movie is very
quiet uh which is to that character's
strength and was part of why I thought I
liked the screenplay so much and it
turns out um that the actor was the one
who cut some of that which I find funny
that the the actor who wrote sicario
tried to write it without Exposition and
then an actor who got cast in sicario
got rid of more Exposition so there's
always more to be removed the whole team
yeah pretty much I mean it's I I love
cutting stuff and I I didn't used to I
think that's probably come from the way
I do my job now is whenever I get to cut
anything I'm like cool trim the fat get
rid of it throw it out in your sculpture
it's not painting it's true man it's
it's it's a challenge for me because
typically like I have no problems coming
in cutting my own dialogue
but if it's something that I've tried to
write or whether it be a script or
whether it be music especially my main
problem is every song I've ever written
started off on guitar and vocal or piano
and vocal and ends up being horns
strings choir all sorts of [ __ ] and I I
agree philosophically with that and I
like aspire to have that that mentality
of like sculpting not painting but by
the end of it it's like this mixed
medium
shellacked and that's why I typically
choose to work with other people is
because it's like hey I've kind of gone
too far down you need to produce a Idina
producer yeah it makes sense
um so Troy I wanted to ask you a
question because we were obviously
talking about the last of us I don't
know how much detail you want to give to
the answer to this all of it do you feel
like the show is significantly different
to the games are there many departures
yes and then also it's it's exactly the
same and
what I what I would tell everyone going
in
um
whether you are a fan of the IP or this
is a brand new introduction for you
I would say
it's not a comparison
it's a companion
and I feel like we've left adaptation
behind and this is now evolution
it is the game exists we've told that
story clearly it's resonated with people
but what if this
and the beauty of it
is that it doesn't change the characters
and it doesn't change the story
to have some things play out completely
differently
um to introduce characters that weren't
there before to iterate on characters
that have been it doesn't change the
story
and
I think that
falling back into the the conversation
we're having before as far as where do
they fail is that too many times they're
like it has to be this
or we're not going to do that at all
as opposed to just going here's the
story we know that it's good
let's try this the fact that we have a
Frank in the show
is a huge departure
but when you tell the story right
and you know that you're doing it with
excellence and you just trust that it's
going to resonate that is the difference
but yeah I mean there's Craig talked
about one thing it's like I can share
this
one of the things that people will see
early on
no spores
that existed as a byproduct of the
function of the necessity of gameplay
mechanic yeah we don't have that and
Craig's like if we if we did that you
would everybody be walking around in a
mask he was like look what we did for
the last two years if somebody sneezed
we wore a mask it's also maybe you like
caught a
performances when everybody's wearing a
mosque in terms of like
harder I bet Pedro was like I did the
Mandalorian way too [ __ ] long yeah
I just love being able to see my [ __ ]
mouth
I I can't wait for people to and the
beauty is the the result of that and and
the the what comes of the what if when
Craig and Neil start spinning that yarn
man is just in insane watching it last
night
um I kind of I was I was doing it like
this because I wanted to see what other
people were going to do specifically
with moments like that
um there are there are big departures
like if you're looking for a frame by
frame shot for shot remake that's not
what this is uh we don't have to do that
we get to do something completely
different that always seems ill-advised
anyway because the more you invite
direct comparison the more you're
invariably gonna
stumble I feel like you know the the
thing will only succeed to the degree
that it asserts its own identity
um I think I think where people get
upset with these adaptations is when
there's like fundamental departures from
what seemingly makes it what it is you
know like if it was if it was you know
um the the temperament of the dynamic
between Joel and Ellie for example like
if that was some
you know
wildly different relations like some
Ultra you know
lovings you know really tender right out
at like something that was like
nothing's earned or it would feel like
all all the matter all the all the
changes in the world could could be fine
or could be acceptable but if certain
Bedrock principles are are treated like
they don't matter
um then uh then you're in you know then
years when you're in trouble with at
least the people who are loyal to the to
the source material I think even to the
audience as well because at that point
you're not you're not telling the same
story
and I think that most people go into an
adaptation not really understanding what
the story is they understand the events
and they understand the character names
and they understand the plot or the
premise most games like the majority of
the story that exactly I was just saying
most games that have been adapted the
story is far less
nuanced and thorough and like this is
this this is a game that always stood
above on account of its writing so right
it like it had such a thoroughly
conceived world of characters and things
like that like you go look at like Sonic
movie you know what exactly story are
they to draw on like it gives them in a
way it gives them a wider birth no no
I'm just saying it's an apples and
oranges situation sure because and
that's how most games are that's why the
Uncharted one was a peculiar example
because it was they had a lot of
potential story and they kind of were
like
Halo thing like the Halo show was just
seemed just seemed really weird to me
for this reason because Halo that first
Halo has a solid narrative to hang your
hats on there's room for adding depth
and nuance and characters to it but like
it's a compelling story or struggle is
it no you don't think so I think so I
think Halo like Halo if you get one into
uh World building yeah there's a lot of
depth to that ODST Jesus Christ
a great show it's true
I do too but I mean uh maybe I'm not as
much of like a Halo Fanboy as as as some
uh because I didn't like half of the
screen yeah maybe there's a mass effect
boy right beneath me
you're pointing at myself
I've left all my halo books downstairs
I've got it I
once we started getting kind of more
into the derivative
aspects of Halo and n World building
um I think there was some there was some
interesting and compelling things but
what it was based upon like if you're
gonna go well we got to start you can't
can't I guess you can you can start with
ODST if you want to
um it's it's a great Standalone
um
or like reach it's like where do you
really start what is canonical
Halo right just rock those it feels like
Halo original game would make an amazing
narrative
I maybe I don't know maybe maybe there's
something about it that I missed to me
what made Halo great and why so many
people played Halo was because of the
PVP aspect it was it was
I think that was the I think that was
the opinion of the people who made the
show but what's weird to me was amazing
too as well yeah for me Halo was the
Cooperative story campaign with my
little sister and just seeing that big
world like first time and [ __ ] it's
just going all over the storytelling of
it and the I the the you know it came
out in you know came out in 2001 right
was it oh maybe yeah when was the Xbox
launch I feel like I was it was
definitely like right around 2000 or
thereafter I remember
2001 2001. so it came out around like
you know September 11th there was a lot
of that stuff in in the news and this
was a story about well but this was the
Halo narrative is about you know
religious solitary and yeah and and both
Halo and Gears of War play with this
idea of this wasn't a good culture like
the the the Halo Mythos is that this was
kind of if not a fascistic Empire of
humans before and like it has a certain
degree of kind of unpleasantness like
the master chief character is kind of
tragic I'm gonna stop before I start
talking about the scene
it is there is depth there you can I I
totally think even the the the
perspective of John 117 being the most
efficient military equipment ever
designed what kind of society creates
him right that's interesting pillar
avoid him gets attacked you end up on an
alien planet with the responsibility of
saving all of mankind because you are
the machine they created to do so I
think is very interesting
it's every James Cameron movie basically
been a little Fool For Hope and snuck in
a little bit but it's all it's it's all
the it's also the disfranchising of that
hero
um it's the disregarding which I think
is a very powerful statement as well so
yeah maybe there's stuff that I just I
do I mean the fact that his job is to
basically protect an AI through the
whole thing like they're like hey dude
we made you this machine hope that's
cool you were plucked out as a child
until you go protect her I will say like
Last of Us and and I think the the kind
of the Aesthetics of naughty dog games
Sony first party in general like
definitely lend the Aesthetics of It
kind of lead your eye more immediately
to where you would do an adaptation for
television or film because they are more
filming they're more cinematic they're
using like you know Last of Us uses a
lot of cinematic tricks along with great
gameplay but it uses a lot of cinematic
storytelling and cinematic pacing and
structure to kind of tell its story so
there is a a more direct path I would
say with adapting one of those stories
than with something like Halo where it's
like there's this really great
section in the novel that came out five
years later you know I mean like there's
yeah there's The Last of Us is a very
great template you could look you could
show that someone never played a game
before and they go oh I see the TV show
in this like I remember when they were
like they're they're turning cormet
McCarthy's book The Road into a movie I
went
what
that's gonna be the script had to be
like 13 pages long because there's no
dialogue
it's all internal dialogues like how do
you how do you do that so there's some
things that I'm like don't adapt and I I
also push against the notion that now
it's gonna be real they're adapting it
for TV or they're turning it into a
movie
interviews then Troy
I I don't think that it has to I think
that the the beauty of like this is an
adaptation was if it failed that proves
that this story could not be told in any
other medium and what a great not
necessarily accidental apologist for
video games that is and as a medium but
to me it just props up the fact that
it's it's a great story and it can be
told here it could be told there you
could do it a graphing novel you can do
it doesn't matter it's a great story
you're going to enjoy it whether you're
on the stick or not but if you haven't
experienced that way there's a whole
other layer
of experiencing this world that's that's
waiting for you
you said you know it's funny how talking
about the difference between that and
Halo
I think that I think this reveals the
kinds of interests that we collectively
focus on with games that make us
probably all of us a bit outliers in the
sense that that
um for me the number one association
with Halos was with Halo was in college
it was like
it was the turning point of Frat Boys
suddenly now thinking it's cool to be
into video games before that video games
were nerds motocross helmet on the alma
as I think I've seen the show before and
they they create a generation of bro
Gamers yeah yeah so I think while there
are there is some subset of the Halo
up you know sort of fan base that
appreciates the Sci-Fi the lore the
characters the story The interesting
questions it raises I think to the point
that you said kind of offhandedly a
second ago Mike probably 90 of the
people that have kept that financially
afloat were people that were really just
into the multiplayer and were and were
probably reasonably new to games which
is why I think that the the showrunners
felt a license to go no one actually
really cares about this story that much
they they see it as a fun shooter
whereas The Last of Us oh I think that's
what I feel really frustrating about the
Halo TV show is they like they touch on
little pieces of it and then just like
throw them around
yeah
that's my thing is that's not an
interesting pitch to me like them you
walking in and going sorry if you're a
creative
you're a creative and most of the people
that you're gonna be pitching to are not
most of the people are pitching to are
like no please give us how these work
out because I talk like this and do this
with my hands for some reason I don't I
I don't I'm not sure genuinely I'm not
sure I agree as someone who has to go
into those rooms and Pitch to those
suits most of them are nerds most of
them are into the stuff they're not
Bankers there are there are those kind
of business people behind those people
but generally when you're pitching
you're pitching to someone who's like
engaged and interested I do believe that
the the system that has been in place
like if you watch the offer whatever and
you see how golf Western was in charge
of Paramount yeah because that was the
thing that they were into that was the
whole days of The Bean counters I do and
I can speak to experience the people
that are at HBO are incredibly creative
and very very passionate they they
obviously have to
there's other platforms that are maybe
not as uh creatively motivated as others
and maybe a little bit more financially
motivated I'm not going to say who
um but I do I have seen that
Um passion leading
um model be prevalent at HBO and I do
think that there's people at like
Disney that are that are like look
they've never put me in a room with kind
of a being counter the B counter like I
think it's because like creative people
in those rooms like how do you know it's
not just that you're you're so Charming
that everyone just becomes interested
she didn't have a shirt on when we
started
I did up a button when I joined that's
the audience will never see that keep it
down it's the John Hamm in 30 Rock kind
of thing right is it just that I'm so
awesome that I don't realize no you're
not Jon Hamm
I love the Tom Cruise cast Jon hammers
the fuddy Dutch he's like 20 years like
younger than Tom Cruise right I love it
um
it's such a good movie I love it
Maverick and Maverick
beautiful as well directed by the guy
who directed Trump Legacy so like
someone who's aesthetic I'm very locked
into uh and very into so yeah that's
wonderful
um May I just quickly before we jump off
of that well I was gonna jump off on to
say that I have watched a bit of the
offer and I didn't
because we had an episode about it and
I've also seen the making of The
Godfather now as well
um and I did you guys like the offer I
don't remember I think you did so I
found it very Moorish and enjoyable but
it was [ __ ] in terms of how it is
yeah it bothers me uh uh that so
entertainment especially a producer
did all of this where's the whole thing
about George Lucas basically forcing him
to make the movie because otherwise
they'd run out of money they're like
George Lucas get him out of here and it
was like such an important part of the
documentary so I think I was just I was
annoyed oh yeah yeah
they create causality which is
compelling storytelling and oh they
can't credit people incorrectly yeah and
I just think I found it a little bit
frustrating as a result of I I think I
enjoyed it more because my knowledge of
the making of The Godfather isn't on
that level it was only after I'd watched
it I did the thing that you always do
after watching something like that
inside Googling like did that really
happen and most of the time it's like no
it didn't no it's probably a better way
to do it yeah there's like one of the
examples that I
um
point out is like the the how the facts
played out is is obviously in service to
the story that they're telling but
doesn't mean that those things didn't
happen like
um uh Bob Evans didn't drive down to
Austin
to go visit Ali McGraw I was a phone
call you know but that's not as that's
not as moving or compelling than him
showing up at her
at her hotel door so uh and find
discovering Steve McQueen on the other
side my impression from reading about it
though like it's much more different
than that my impression from reading
about it was because it is written based
specifically around what's his name
miles tellers
um the producer it's amazing yeah you
can tell watching it right like you can
tell it's a story written by that
character because for sure everything
yeah yeah but the Imp I Googled after
each episode
um you know the kind of highlight claims
and most of them were not things that
seemed cut and dry [ __ ] so much as
as contested by the various people
involved like where there's a spectrum
of you know if if there's some coup
associated with you know pulling off
some great thing with the the production
of it he kind of gives himself Soul
credit
um other people argued that it was their
job reality is it probably was some
blurry mixture of overlapping factors
and I I didn't get the impression that
that
it was straight up [ __ ] so much as
as you know favorably tilted in his way
Beyond probably the most purified truth
but that very little seemed whole cloth
fabricated there were a couple things I
remember reading they were like this
probably didn't happen at all this way
um but most of it yeah most of it's kind
of like what Troy's saying where it was
you know they they played things up
here's a question that I have though but
I don't know I'm not an expert in terms
of did you enjoy it as as a as a show
Alana
I had trouble disconnecting those two
things
um and like I would say I do see it as
[ __ ] it just because I think maybe
part of my problem is that I see it as
somebody's personal hero fantasy rather
than the actual complications of how
this thing was made if it was if it was
purely fictional
movie yeah yeah I think it's I just had
trouble disconnecting okay the making of
documentary
because I think that there's
going again to adaptations my
understanding of it was from Bob Evans
perspective which of course he talks a
little bit of a cocaine problem for a
while
um that and that's like a footnote and
then you know a couple people came to
him and was like get your [ __ ] together
but
his like the kid stays in the picture is
his version of of that whole thing and
not just a Godfather but also Rosemary's
Baby and everything else he did
subsequent
um
but I think that
so I was looking at it
and I started to do the comparison thing
too and I was like okay hold on that's
not the story that we're telling this is
the story that we're telling and am I on
board for that story and that to me is
is a a thing that kept me from going
well hold on a second I think that
proximity was probably my issue was that
I was like let me watch something yeah I
think but
yeah the thing I would just throw in
there is that what I loved about it so
much was that it was basically just a
continuous stream of people super
passionate about filmmaking right and
like as a study of that completely
irrespective of if it's true I just
loved seeing
I I'm a I'm a real sucker for for that
sort of sub-genre of like passionate
people sort of bending over backwards to
try to create I loved the bit with with
um Coppola and the DP arguing about you
know if you want me to light them and
give you you know faces partially in
Shadow partially in light the actors
have to hit their marks and couple of
just screaming saying if if you know
they're not robots if you don't if you
don't give the actors the space to
explore the room they're not going to be
able to act appropriately well then I
then I cannot light it the way you're
asking and the way it's like you have
these irreconcilable Vantage points
because both people want it to be great
and to me people are right yeah of
course exactly they they they they they
are having a hard time giving credence
to the fact that the other person has a
valid point interesting thing about the
making of The Godfather is that almost
nobody wanted to make it everybody was
against making it I mean or making the
worst version of it yeah the worst
version
that's not [ __ ] I was like how is
that gonna be your [ __ ] poster
there's so many things about that that
they're like you you go one degree off
and you're a failure yeah
but at the end of the day
it started with the story and the story
was good so who knows maybe if they'd
come out with that poster or if they had
gotten different casting we would have
been sitting here talking about how
great
who else you know the the 30 other
people that they had for
um Michael
yeah it wasn't originally supposed to be
Martin Sheen that was going to be
Michael he was going to play Tom so we
could have been lauding their
performances I have no idea you know
Maria Puzo after adapting the screenplay
from his own book obviously uh when he
went on to write another
when he went so then this fact are you
no I don't think so when he went to
writing another screenplay he felt very
Superman he did write Superman it was
his next drill well before writing
Superman then
um he was insecure about writing
screenplays and wasn't sure how to do it
so he read a book on writing screenplays
and it recommended reading the Mario
Puzo screenplay
wow snake eating its own tail holy [ __ ]
which I'm actually not really I really
should read that screenplay yeah
basically the advice was read your own
work dude he was like maybe I am okay
maybe I can do this here's something
interesting going back to Maverick
because I wanted to
um I uh as a Christmas present I gave
Travis Willingham is a huge huge fan of
Top Gun is his favorite movie
and so
um I found a signed script uh signed by
Tom scarrett to give him and so he's
thumbing through this he was like uh
that's not in the movie
um that's gone uh it was it was so
interesting to see like the different
variations and this is like probably
fourth draft but it was far enough along
that character names were in there and
Tom scarrett had one so typically if you
have that cast it's not like you're he
he probably was in second round third
round of casting you get it you get your
big heavy you're gonna get your main
guys and you're gonna move on so this
had made it through the paces for for a
while and versions of the script were
like oof yeah you definitely cut all of
that and it changes the characters
there was a
um reading scripts is a great practice
but it was what I guess the point big
fan yeah yeah and and and that's that
exploration of like what gets cut
um
I
saw an example of that just this past
weekend that I didn't know about I was
at
um this event the music and games
Festival in Washington DC magfest and
they have this event called like voice
of palooza or something like that where
it's a bunch of voice actors
um just being silly basically and and
they did this one bit where they they
they divvied up uh the all the various
parts
um
um
of the
uh last scene of Wrath of Khan there it
is
um and had everybody read it and
actually I thought felt very snl-esque
into because it was a funny idea that
was probably twice as long as it needed
to be but uh
um every they basically had the
explanation now the bit well okay fair
enough but it was an interesting thing
because
um they they read through the final
scene and I never remembered
before as Spock is dying in the like
radiation chamber thing and he says yeah
he you know they do all the meat right
needs of the many needs of the few
friends and then yeah you exactly I will
I am now and will forever be your friend
there's a line in there that I thought
was cut because they read it and I was
like that seems like such a awkward
Middle where he says something to the
effect of what do you think of my
solution to the Kobayashi Maru
um and I remember thinking that must
have because they were reading from a
from what I assumed was a shooting
script and I thought I said I hadn't
been that had to have been cut
um
I went back
um yeah I went back and watched it again
and and and it is there he does say that
and it was one of those where I was like
wow it's amazing how that that feels
like such an inorganic thing to ins it
feels like equip it's like equipped too
far for this for this intimate moment
and the death of this seminal the
temporary death of this seminal
character
um and that I completely erased that
from my from my head like yeah I kind of
have still never did that
you know in his radiation dying Voice
through because of the way that it's
delivered and that it'll be cut out
please pause the podcast now and YouTube
that scene from Star Trek 2. 12 minutes
yeah exactly
no it's not 12 minutes I don't know it
was a guess of like you know how you try
to get that is 12 minutes
12 minutes and three seconds you know
the story behind that
no go ahead so so Spock does die about
12 minutes into Wrath of Khan they have
a they do the Kobayashi Maru and he he
pretends to die
um
one of the reasons that scene's in there
is because they knew that he was the
fact that he would was dice in the film
would be kind of leaked and talked about
by fans so that scene's purpose back
when the film came out was you would
watch it you go oh that's what people
were talking about when they said that
Spock dies and then you carry on with
the film it's a deliberate
technique
a leak or or a spoiler just conversation
just the the it would get out because
they knew that the Star Trek audience
was very talkative and the fans
well it was at that point largely women
like it was a massive it was what Star
Trek was one of the first things that
kind of had like a very vocal fans in
pop culture kind of conversation well
obviously well before the internet that
was
um something that they were very aware
of and they were aware that that would
lead to that story going out so it's
deliberately there so that when you get
to that scene you're like oh it's the
bit my friend told me about and then you
you get you know full sentence though
just if I'm not mistaken that was in the
the term was introduced in the
show first brought back into
well on the scene no the scene yeah the
scenes there like structurally it's it's
an important thing that narratively
works the thing I'm specifically
referring to is there is a Spock during
that exercise yeah and then he says I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead Jim or something
right he's like Wikipedia
it's definitely there for more than just
this it's definitely there yeah because
obviously they bring it back it's a big
thing in the the new movie with um Chris
Pine but was it I I thought that they
brought it up in
the original series it's the one Star
Trek show I'm not obsessively nerdly
aware of otherwise ask me any other Star
Trek trivia I can do it like wait the
original series we talked about this
before the original series no I'm I come
in the next gen and they're not obsessed
can you do me a favor yeah can you watch
uh City on the edge of forever okay
that's the one with the big time portal
thing yes look Kobayashi Maru is a
reference to komagata Maru I had no idea
that makes it like
cooler kind of sad it's based on the
actual death of 22 people for anyone who
didn't know at home the common God of
Maru incident involved the Japanese
steamship kamagata maroon which a group
of people from British India attempt to
immigrate to Canada in April 1914 but
most of the denied entry and forced to
return to budge budge Calcutta they're
the Indian Imperial police attempted to
arrest the group leaders a riot and
shoot and they were fired upon by police
resulting in the deaths of 22 people yep
that is what Kobayashi Maru is named
after based on not the biggest human
tragedy that Star Trek has referenced
but which one all right go ahead go
ahead
biggest try probably 90.
there you go because the series Star
Trek Enterprise uh following following
911 second time it's come on both times
brought up by me
um what Enterprise has it's like Florida
gets blown up by aliens right that's in
in Enterprise like the next season and
then there's like a war on terror in
Enterprise where they go and the zindy
if I recall correctly are this alien
species they're hunting down and I'm
getting bored as I was describing
I know I it's sad how much of my my
teenage brain was dedicated to just
learning all this trivia it's ridiculous
why was there a was there just a desire
for the knowledge or did you find it
useful like were you like I need to I
need to learn about this well no it's I
think the chicken in the egg are the
other way around I got really obsessed
with it because it was an interesting
and you know as a nerdy kid
somewhat kind of hyper fixation yeah
exactly like let's not diagnosed me on
the call but definitely like an interest
in in kind of becoming obsessively aware
of things the World building of that and
how consistent Star Trek and Star Trek
has loads of contradictions in it but
like more so than most pop culture it's
incredibly like it works logically the
chronology Etc I feel like that's got me
interested and I I do I do think one of
the reasons as an adult that I've gone
into writing and specifically the World
building side of writing is is is that
childhood interest I think that's that's
definitely part of it I think that we
always I know that I do this I I will
embellish my passions or I will I will
seek the tools necessary to increase my
capacity for my passions so if there's
something passionate about
I just follow I have two comments and
then I unfortunately have to run despite
the fact that I was egregiously late
um we're not wasting your time are we
Austin yeah
I was I was indeed I want to I want to
if you guys are able to uh get a hold of
your like end of year steam stats uh
next week mines all over the map by the
way that's why I I'd rather save it for
the next time
in the last year so yeah very boring is
it yours
I know that everybody says that but I
still feel like it's underrated you know
how sometimes you're like this is
actually rated quite well and everyone
who likes it uh really likes it but I
still feel like it's it doesn't get the
Justice it deserves
people still refer to like Thomas Was
Alone as underrated and it's brilliant
nobody says that
I promise you they do all the time shut
up
um
it's cool people keep talking about
things the worst thing to be is like
fine
you want to be memorable or not yep that
was all right
somebody came up and they were like I
know everybody hates last was part two I
was like who who hates it
oh you went wrong
in the first game Who hates it
give me their names
what does Punchy mean do you meant that
you drank Punch or you were boxing I was
just it was uh pull them up I was just a
little uh roughrous
it's a good thing that Italy is a
non-extradition country yeah not welcome
back there yeah Austin what was your
second note the second note was when you
were talking about getting into the uh
uh the sort of nerdy deep Dives
um
a game that I just wanted to turn into a
shout out that was a great game or it
was a great band in the early 2000s
there's both they opened for Wilkins
yeah the um
I played a I played a zillion games in
December as part of the dice jury and
the one that got its hooks in me uh what
get out of here uh the one that got its
hooks in me for exactly that reason Mike
I loved the the like as a way to do
sci-fi World building in a totally
different way in was
um shipbreaker did you play that I did
I've got a few mates who worked and I do
need to check that out it's so I found
it I found it inexplicably addicting but
the idea that you learn you learn about
the World by what you learn about these
ships in order to take them apart that's
it one of my friends obsessed with Ship
Breaker she brings up [ __ ] Breakers so
often that I feel like it's required
playing at this point is it called it
unpacking for dudes
is it like a session gamer like kind of
thing where it's like you're gonna sit
down you're gonna play like a round kind
of thing or is it the individual
missions tend to be 15 minutes so it's
really really good in and out and but I
just found it I just found it just like
endlessly engrossing the idea simulator
you learn about the world during the
power washing
and like this is an example of like
um the Maya of the town is kind of a
[ __ ] but you sort of learned that at the
point Mario you exactly and theme
Bioshock movie why we've come full
circle everyone you go to power washers
house which has been egged
um but he won't open the gate for you
because he doesn't want you to enter the
house so the the level is you have to
power wash the eggs off the mayor's
house but he won't actually let you on
the tip on the premises I'm like
somebody got really high made that game
I I love it but that is I mean though
that is the kind of like that that is
precisely uh you know what I don't know
it to me it was a game that I of all the
ones that I played that was the one that
I just kept coming back to and I was
like I know I have others to do I think
that's why I haven't played it it sounds
it does sound really good because I got
so obsessed with power wash emulator
that I don't need more of those games
tournament should I keep playing that oh
I loved it
all right
there's a train in the opening
it's funny because that's the first
episode
this is literally the first episode
where you're referencing the first
episode
we started this show in 2019. I know I
think I've gained a beard and glasses
and several gray hairs since then so
yeah it's been a long time I've aged
like 2023 first episode I I saw a camera
last night and I was afraid he was gonna
call me out for some reason thinking
that he like watches this or that he
knew that and he was like yeah man I I
love playing The Last of Us I was
waiting for the other shoe to drop to be
like
Cameron
you never got off the train never got
off the train
um and I never got off the train all
right everybody thank you for joining us
happy 2023 and we will see you next week
hopefully you get an intro or what I'm
doing it right now Troy shut up
shut up Mike I'm doing it right now
that's Mike bipple he's a video game
director that's awesome winter he's been
listen we will see you next week maybe
maybe
[Music]
[Music]